it is that time again when people are
enrolling for Medicare and finding out
whether they're eligible for that and
these volunteers are on hand to answer
your questions call that number on your
screen with your individual questions
about Medicare eligibility we have with
us Dr garabs wrath thank you so much for
being here let's talk about who is
eligible for Medicare excellent question
so there's multiple ways that someone
can be eligible for Medicare the first
one is if you're over the age of 65 then
you are eligible to get the Medicare
benefits if you're not over the age of
65 let's say you happen to be under 65
but you have certain disabilities that
can also qualify you for Medicare
benefits additionally if you're not 65
but have certain medical conditions like
end-stage renal disease ALS that also
allows you to be to receive medicare
benefits also if you already have
Medicare there's certain periods
throughout the year where you can
actually change your plan to a different
plan what have you and if you have
Medicare benefits already in a different
state and you relocate to a new city new
state that also allows you to pick a
makes you eligible to get new benefits
in the new state great information as
always we so appreciate you being here
doctors wrath thank you so much all
right Mercedes back to you
coming up